y el río de janeiro ha ganado eduardo
paes con el 64% y la novedad es que ha
ganado en prácticamente todos los
distritos la campaña contra el candidato
apoyado por el presidente jair bolsonaro
ha sido muy fuerte marcelo crivella es
un obispo evangélico que ha sido muy
criticado por su gestión a lo largo de
los últimos cuatro años por su pasividad
pero también por su falta de empatía con
el tipo de carioca que ama el carnaval y
que ama el samba en ese sentido país es
el típico carioca que defiende las
fiestas locales que defiende el carnaval
que es el acontecimiento económico más
importante el de río de janeiro pero
claro es una persona bastante polémica
porque tiene varios líos en la justicia
ha sido investigado en varias ocasiones
por corrupción aunque de momento no le
han encontrado nada pero tiene varios
frentes abiertos en la justicia en san
paolo otra novedad
boulos
recibe el 40 por ciento de los votos
bonos es una activista a favor de la
vivienda social y a favor de la
ocupación de
edificios vacíos ha sido muy criticado
por la derecha tradicionalmente pero ha
hecho una campaña electoral muy para acá
está muy didáctica y ha conseguido subir
mucho en esas elecciones y aunque haya
ganado el actual prefecto bruno cobas de
un partido de centroderecha tradicional
se considera bolo es una gran novedad en
el panorama político nacional